Imagine a utopian world.
What does your world look like?
My world is full of colors;
some colors are indescribable.
The trees are vibrant and swish
in the gentle breeze.
Meadows are full of a variety
of bright flowers.
Nature flourishes next to bustling cities.
People are agreeable to one another
and are open to different perspectives.
My world lacks ignorance and overflows
with compassion and understanding
for one another.
It is fueled by love.
My world is fueled by a love of nature,
a love of knowledge,
a love of empathy,
a love for one another,
and most of all,
a love for our future, our children.
My world is a world where every child is
born with potential and equal opportunity.
Children are the future
and governments realize this.
They invest more into the success and
education of the future.
It is not a world ripe with violence
or greed,
but one of peace and kindness.
And it most definitely is a world
where each and every child on this screen
have no obstacles pertaining to their
racial and/or ethnic backgrounds.
While some of the attributes of my utopian
world are seemingly unattainable,
others should make us wonder.
Why is it that the idea of every child
being born with potential
and equal opportunity
only one of a dream world?
"What?" you may ask, "Isn't that already
something of the present?
We all have the same amount
of opportunity at birth, right?"
No. They do not.
We have a problem.
Racial judgments
are ruining children's lives.
For simplicity, let's define racial judgments
as judgments related to race and ethnicity.
We live in a world where a child's future
is almost set in stone
the moment that they are conceived,
a future that is primarily dependent
on ethnicity.
Our carelessness and our lack
of awareness when making judgments
is destructive to our children,
our future.
Yes, we have a huge problem,
but we also have a great solution.
Take a look at the group of children
projected on the screen.
What do you see?
Do you see a diverse group
of children eagerly waiting to answer?
We have all determined
that these children are adorable.
How old do they look?
They seem to be in preschool,
or more likely kindergarten
or first grade.
Do you see anything else in this picture?
Anything else at all?
Have you made all your observations?
Here are a few observations
that most of you probably didn't make.
Let's consider a hypothetical situation.
This is more or less your typical
preschool claass.
So, let's say that James,
the white boy in the first row,
bites Lily's hand, the Japanese
girl to his right of him,
because she wouldn't give him her crayon.
On average, the worst punishment
James will get
is a phone call home and a time out.
Fair enough, right?
Ok, same situation, but let's have
Daniel bite Lily's hand.
Daniel is more likely to be suspended,
if not expelled.
In fact, black males are three times
more likely to be suspended
than their white counterparts
for the same misbehavior,
a trend that holds for preschool
as well as the rest of their
educational careers.
The idea of black males being
persecuted far more severely
than their white counterparts
is prevalent throughout the child's life.
An example of this is seen in the
school-to-prison pipeline,
which states that male African Americans
are more likely to go to prison
straight from school.
While the situation above is hypothetical,
it is based off of a real-life incident.
These racial judgments start
in the very beginning, preschool.
The black girl in the picture, Katie,
is facing consequences just as extreme,
if not more extreme.
According to a study conducted by
Columbia University law professor
Kimberle Williams Crenshaw,
black girls and other girls of color
are facing a grave danger.
While black boys are only three times
more likely to be suspended,
black girls are six times more prone
to suspension
than their white female classmates.
In a Baltimore school, a school security
officer claimed to be attacked
by three black girls.
The school immediately believed
the officer and expelled the three girls.
However, after reviewing a security tape,
it was shown that the officer had
repeatedly hit one of the girls
on the head with her baton
and pepper sprayed the other girls,
forcing all three girls to seek treatment
at a hospital.
Why is that?
Why are these girls in more danger
than white girls?
Well, the study goes on to explain
that black girls and other girls of color
are seen as disruptive and ignorant.
Their achievements are ignored
and their actions are misinterpreted.
Like, for instance, the study claims
that the majority of its participants
believed that their teachers
viewed them negatively
and often berated them for being defiant
when, in fact,
they were just being curious.
Furthermore, the girls of color
are facing an intersectional burden
since their darker skin is associated
with aggressive behavior,
and as women,
they have the additional burden
of being seen as bossy and demanding
when they are being assertive.
Thus the discrimination that girls
of color face
can be far more onerous than that
of boys of color
because of the difference in gender.
Racial judgments are ruining
children's lives.
Not only black children,
other children as well.
When we see an Asian person,
we immediately assume
they must be super smart.
That being said, white people also
have to deal with racial judgments.
They are typically taken as more racist
and more judgmental than any other race.
Consider this picture of teens
from different ethnic backgrounds
speaking out against the racial judgments
they combat.
These judgments are based off of
stereotypes,
and these generalizations
have become jokes.
We have forgotten that our words
can actually do damage.
Let's not forget the racial judgments
concerning religion.
The Pew Research Center conducted
a survey
where they asked Americans to rate
how warmly they felt about Muslims
on a thermometer scale
from 0 degrees to 100 degrees.
The average temperature was 40 degrees,
significantly cooler than that of
the rest of the seven religious groups
that were also surveyed.
This is because, one, they base their
judgment off of a small percentage
of extremist Muslims,
and two, they're ignorant to what
the religion actually stands for.
This is a problem I myself face
as a young Muslim woman.
Racial judgments are the reason why I,
a sixteen-year-old girl,
am pulled aside during airport security.
While I understand that it's for
my own safety,
it is tiring and concerning that the
people around me
may be afraid of me or hate me
because of a piece of clothing,
my hijab, on my head.
These types of racial judgments will
surely affect Aaliyah,
the Indian Muslim girl in the back row.
I, like the majority of Muslims,
as well as the majority of the world,
absolutely abhor terrorists.
In every group of people, there is always
going to be a small percentage
of people who are so extreme that
the larger group must disown them.
But no matter how we try to
separate ourselves from these criminals,
our physical similarities are too much
for people to overcome.
Simply because we share
the same color of skin
or piece of clothing
with these terrorists,
we become targets
of the same racial judgments.
In our nation, many of us hold ideals
that race shouldn't matter,
that most of us have overcome almost
all racial barriers
and problems caused by race.
Our statement is a half truth.
It is true that most of us have overcome
racial barriers
concerning friendship
and other aspects of life.
However, there are still so many aspects
of our lives where race, unfortunately,
still matters.
In many cases, our racial backgrounds
determine the level
of educational opportunity we have,
the types of lives we will lead,
and the way we are perceived by society.
We shouldn't always ignore race.
Sometimes, knowing a
person's beliefs or race
can help you become more respectful
towards that person.
It can broaden your horizons
and help you form judgments
that aren't biased and/or ignorant.
We can't stop racial judgments
or judgments all altogether.
Judging is an evolutionary trait,
something we needed for our survival.
Simple judgments, like knowing
when to cross the street,
or knowing not to go into
a dark alleyway at night,
are essential for human life,
which is why stopping racial judgments
is nearly impossible
and detrimental to our species.
Here's what we can do.
We can become aware
of our racial judgements
Our awareness will make us think
twice about our judgments.
It is proven that actively looking
for biases in your racial judgments
will make your judgments more accurate
and respectful.
This is because racial judgments
are products of implicit bias,
a bias in assumptions and behavior
that occur on a subconscious level.
It is due to the assumptions
and stereotypes
that we are exposed to
in our respective environments.
Implicit bias is automatic,
but it's not intransigent.
Awareness is the key.
Next time we find ourselves making
an assumption about someone,
we need to ask ourselves, why?
Do we have a good reason?
Would we be able to justify
our assumption
to someone with a different perspective?
When we ask ourselves these questions,
we tend to second-guess ourselves,
and in this case, this is a good thing.
If we second-guess ourselves,
our racial judgments will become
more accurate,
more respectful,
and less biased.
I'm not saying this will be easy.
It's hard.
I'm ashamed to admit that I have succumbed
to biased racial judgments.
I've walked down the street
with my best friend
and we have deliberately changed our pace
or route to avoid
and African American or white man
in baggy clothing.
But I think we're taking the first step
in making better racial judgments
when we realize that some of our
judgments are biased.
I've often found myself judging someone
without realizing
and then mentally berating
myself right after.
So become more aware.
Ask yourselves the reasons behind your
judgments and assumptions.
This will help you become more aware
of your judgments and of your thoughts.
If not for your own sake,
for the sake of those little preschoolers,
for the sake of our world's future.
This awareness will brighten our world,
creating a safe space for all of our
children to thrive and achieve
their hopes and dreams.
And someday, my utopian world,
our utopian world,
will become a reality.
Thank you.